foreign
I've done this experiment I ask people
where's the Sun at 12 noon and
invariably more than half the cases they
Point straight up straight up and what's
what's odd is it means they've never
looked
because for the entire continental
United States right at no time of day
and no day of the year okay is the sun
ever directly overhead you know why I
think it's difficult because it's hard
to look at the Sun
yes and you shouldn't look at the Sun
but you might notice maybe at noon the
Shadows go away because it's pointing
straight down but so it just means
modern people just not observant the
repeat things they've heard and puts the
word high in front of noon leaves people
thinking that it's directly over it it's
just not true it leaves some people
thinking it's directly over here it
leaves other people thinking something
totally different I know it very it's
very Western concept right yes it's
where you kill a man in the middle of
the day no Chuck no stop
no it's not what you it's where you have
a shootout whether or not anybody dies
that's right that's right true true all
right meet you at High Noon all right so
the there are places on Earth where the
sun is occasionally directly overhead
and it's between 23 and a half degrees
north latitude and 23.5 degrees south
latitude and 23.5 degrees is the tilt of
Earth's axis okay in our orbit so that's
where that number comes from but if you
go in that range those are what we call
the tropics
and there are days of the year where the
sun is actually directly overhead
okay cool if you're between those two
zones and the Tropic of Cancer is
false just below Key West
just below Key West okay so so that's
why nobody in the continental United
States Hawaii is about 15 degrees north
latitude so Hawaii gets to experience
this but not anybody else in the in the
continental United States so the general
Trend here is the farther away you are
from the equator
the closer you are to the poles right
the lower the noontime sun gets
you okay
so if in the tropics it's occasionally
directly overhead as you inch your way
out of the tropics the noontime Sun
gets lower and lower and lower in the
sky right okay now that will change
seasonally in New York City where we
live where we record Star Talk the noon
Sun
in the winter on December 21st first day
of winter doesn't get more than 26
degrees above the Horizon oh that's high
noon December 21st wow now you go to
June 21st
the high noon sun is higher but still
not directly overhead that's all right
directly overhead would be 90 degrees up
it's about I got to look it up for 74
degrees something like that wow that's
high but it's not but that's a long way
from directly overhead a long way from
directly overhead okay yeah so all I'm
saying is that the highest the sun gets
in any day of the year is lower as you
approach the polls
okay gotcha okay all right so
you keep marching you get to the Arctic
Circle okay 66 and a half degrees
of latitude
so when you hit the Arctic Circle there
is a day where the Sun never sets and it
stays that way throughout the summer and
then it dropped drift back down to the
Horizon and then it goes below the
Horizon for the winter months and then
it's not to be seen again until
summertime so they basically just have
day and night
yes two seasons day and night
exactly day and night all right so now
that makes an interesting fact
okay
let's go to the Moon
all right let's go to the moon and go to
the polls
all right okay let's go to the South
Pole no different we can go to the North
Pole but I got we got good stuff going
on in the South Pole for this explainer
okay right so you go to the South Pole
as you approach the pole the Sun
the height of the sun above the Horizon
doesn't get very high right
just like I described here on Earth
right okay so the noontime sun in the
South Pole of the Moon
is very low on the horizon okay are we
there okay okay now
there are craters on the moon yes as
you've surely seen some craters
are at the South Pole the craters
everywhere summer and so craters have
rims okay
rims that stick up a little bit above
the terrain right all right hmm craters
are deep yes
I got a deep crater and a rim and I'm at
the South Pole
oh my gosh
when the Sun is up
at the Moon South Pole it does not get
high enough
to peer Above the Rim of the crater
so the base of some craters at the lunar
South Pole never ever see sunlight
wow
okay so it is literally where the sun
don't shine
okay now there's another South Pole with
this guy just let you know
okay hey guys apologies for the
interruption but I wanted to take a
quick break and thank our partners at
ag-1 for sponsoring today's video those
of you who've been following know that
I've been taking nt1 consistently for
the last month and I gotta say I love it
I've noticed that I have more energy and
I no longer get that 3 30 p.m crash that
makes my day like super super difficult
now that's my personal experience but
I'd love to hear what ag1 is doing for
you if you don't already know ag1 is a
daily foundational nutrition that
supports whole body Health with
self-report stating that 92 percent of
Americans have at least one kind of
vitamin deficiency it's important that
we get our nutrients in where we can
it's quick
easy and for a schedule like mine it is
necessary to fit into my everyday
routine and I do take it every day so
whether you're looking up your daily
dose of vitamin C zinc biotin or other
micronutrients or phytonutrients to keep
your body in check you should consider
giving a G1 a shot if you're interested
in trying it for yourself make sure you
visit
drinkag1.com StarTalk to get a free
one-year supply of ag-1 vitamin D3 plus
K2 and 5 ag1 travel packs with your
first purchase by the way the travel
packs are great for fitting into my
lifestyle thanks again to our friends at
ag1 for sponsoring today's video
what's interesting on the moon is
because there's no air
and there's no
Sky get getting illuminated by sunlight
right why do we have a blue sky because
light comes from the sun scatters into
the atmosphere so you say oh we have
clear skies actually no you're looking
at Blue Lights scattered off of air
molecules right you're not actually
looking at the universe right the
universe is cloaked by the scattered
light and because the scatter light is
everywhere if something's in a shadow
it's a little darker but you can see it
because life's coming from everywhere
other than the sun as well
right all right I mean think about it if
the sun were over to the left and
there's a tree and the tree makes a
shadow you shouldn't be able to see
anything inside the shadow because the
sun is not Illuminating it it should be
completely dark but it's not
because light is coming from all the
scattered light elsewhere in the
atmosphere on the moon where there is no
atmosphere there's no scattered Light
Shadows Are Pitch Black
oh
all right that's actually kind of cool
it is kind of cool it is kind unless you
have something reflecting light into the
shadow right there's no scattered light
from the atmosphere but and by the way
that's why you can see stars in the
daytime with the sun sitting in the sky
oh by the way there are people who are
sure we did not land on the moon and
they looked at the photos
of Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin in
daylight and they say we know you're
supposed to see stars in daylight and I
don't see any stars in this photo all
right okay so therefore we didn't really
go to the Moon
as though NASA wouldn't know to fake
that if that were the case
and that's her idiots that that kind of
makes a lot of sense if you know that
well then we the space people definitely
knew it too definitely no too so why
wouldn't we just throw a little dots in
the back and let you see some Stars okay
what the person doesn't know is how
photography works okay the terrain is so
bright from the sun right the aperture
of the camera closes down and cannot
register the like the same things such
as the stars in the sky so that's why
that's how that plays out there you go
that's true all right so let's get back
to the South Pole okay so it's not the
Sun not only doesn't shine there you
can't even see in it all right so now
what's making these craters
um some well a meteor or something yeah
thank you I don't ask complicated
questions
okay so meteors can be made of rock or
they can made of ice they're Comet
fragments that are out there so both can
make these craters right all right so
now
if a comet hits the Moon
and the so the material is now not rock
it's like water and other ices like
ammonia ice and things let's look focus
on the water the water molecules there's
a lot of energy there it'll evaporate
the water molecule flies up okay and
then falls back to the moon's surface
all right right all right well if it
falls to a part of the surface that's in
sunlight it'll eventually evaporate and
Escape right but suppose it happens to
fall where the sun don't shine
it stays Frozen it stays Frozen it's
called a cold trap that's the official
term for it cold trap and falls in there
and it stays there for billions of years
let me say that right billions
billions of years and so
the next mission to the Moon
Artemis okay the the one where we're
gonna land Artemis three right okay this
is NASA's mission to Artemis is the twin
sister of Apollo
and Artemis was the goddess of the moon
and other other than other related
things so they're they're targeting the
South Pole to land
to check and verify that there's water
there inside those craters
we think we not only think there is
theoretically we have some measurements
that there's likely water there and now
we're going to go and verify for sure
because if there is you don't need to
bring water to the Moon to to drink
oh look at that it's part is what's
called isru in situ resource utilization
which is a NASA thing and uh so why why
bring sand to the beach why bring water
to the Moon oh
I like that why bring sand to the beach
very good unless your Beach ain't got no
sand
it's a rocky Beach at my break and it's
right right so
so all of this is related to the fact
that the sun doesn't get very high in
the sky at the poles that's all that's
why I started on Earth and I landed on
the moon for this explainer that's very
cool that and I love I love it that's
why NASA we're checking out this album
it'll be a geologically chemically
interesting next place to visit
wow so we go to the Moon to look for
water in a cold trap in a cold trap and
they'll need their own lights to see
their way around right plus I I it's not
this way because it's like molecule
deposits but you'd have to mine the
water through the material you bring the
lunar material through and sift out the
water molecules and then you have a
puddle of water what they could do is
sprinkle the water back in and then go
ice skating maybe okay that's kind of
cool unless it's too cold to ice skate
that could happen
ice can be too cold to skate on yeah
which was we did that one a long time
long long time ago that's a uh that's a
great that's a great explainer if you
want to look it up hi Chuck we gotta run
oh man that was cool man all right well
I can't wait for them to find water on
the moon where the sun don't shine
all right I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson Chuck
thanks for being there as always a
pleasure all right start talk keep
looking up
foreign
[Music]